if there's a married couple and they
don't have evolutionary insights into
their relationship and their their
values and preferences and and
what drives their reactions i think like
why would you handicap yourself that way
like it's really sad you'd be much
better to go back to like
read the moral animal by robert wright
rather than go to marital therapy
like do both but
jesus read something about human nature
if if you really care about your
relationship what do you wish more
married couples knew
i wish more married couples knew
that
you don't have to take your
emotional reactions nearly as seriously
as you typically do
for example
um
a lot of
people think
okay i know i'm not supposed to like
hit my spouse i'm not supposed to do
physical violence to my spouse and so if
i have an impulse to do that
i have to control that that's not
civilized that's bad
however there's a lot of other
um reactions we have that are basically
uh what economists call punishment
routines
like somebody else does something that
pisses you off
right and you have a reaction to punish
them to give some negative reinforcement
this can range from i want to hit them
to i want to cuss at them to i don't
want to talk to them for a day
to i want to complain about them to my
friends
or god forbid on social media
those are all punishment routines
the instinct to want to punish them
even over something that's
maybe objectively trivial can be very
strong
but we have this double standard where
like we go okay physical punishment
that's super bad we don't do that in a
civilized marriage
but all these other things
right are still considered kind of fair
game
even if they're objectively like a
massive overreaction
to what actually happened
i think conversely
if you understand like why we want to
punish
our mate for certain like transgressions
you then you can actually play with that
like you can make it funny you can kind
of playfully exaggerate it
my wife my wife diane and i do this all
the time like
um
if she's pissed off at me for
whatever failing to do something in the
kitchen
instead of
taking it seriously and going oh my god
jeffrey you suck you're such a bad
husband
she'll start like mouthing
nonsense syllables
but in an angry way in kind of a
self-mocking way and so she'll be like
[Laughter]
and then i'll start arguing back
using like
my defensive
like nonsense syllables like
why can we do that because we're both
evolutionary psychologists and we both
know at some level
the desire to over punish for trivial
stuff is is just ridiculous and if you
understand
how ridiculous it can be
then you can make
fun of your own reactions
and then you're actually like closer to
each other
because like i have the faith that she
has enough self-insight
that she can mock her own like feminine
programming yeah
and she has confidence i have enough
insight into my sort of masculine nature
and programming that i can make fun of
it
and
by contrast you go to marital therapy
most therapists will be like you all
have to be a hundred percent earnest
all the time about your feelings and you
have to take your feelings seriously and
like express them
and
and work through them and talk it out so
diana if you were angry that jeffrey had
used the source and not put it away and
you felt upset about it then this is
justified we do not have any unjustified
feelings in this that's [ __ ]
interesting i've never been to
counseling uh
but i imagine
in movies where i've seen it that's what
they do
yeah and it's just
very few good role models in movies or
tv about how to manage these things like
you'll almost never see somebody in a
serious adult drama
actually make fun of their own reactions
in a kind of wise and insightful way the
only time that you would ever see it is
kind of the ditzy
female classic american ditzy suburbs
early 30s still not married like wine
ant
type lovable
like always the bridesmaid never the
bride type one like oh here i go again
losing my [ __ ] about something that
doesn't really matter which is kind of
touching the reason that people laugh at
it is the fact that they know
there is a compulsion that is a part of
her programming that had if she had all
of her uh rational capabilities she
might
dial that back she might tamp that down
a little bit it's just that
you try to turn that up to 11.
yeah so that those are two big takeaways
like try to have some insight into
yourself and then try to be playful with
it what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace